Just let me say a few of the key
messages,
I mean other people think that you still
have to wait for new brakes with
technology and I don't think that's the
case.
We have to existing technologies,
but they have to break through and that
doesn't come by itself and uncle venture
gas and America wasn't a big surprise to
everyone say in the last decade,
but the first pioneers were already out
there trying to develop the technology
in the eighties.
So it takes a few decades,
about three decades for new technology
to really come through.
And that's a very normal timespan,
uh,
in the energy industry,
this industry to actually have new
technologies coming on stream to about
one percent market share when it
actually becomes competitive with
existing incumbents.
So bear that in mind three decades
before it becomes competitive,
another three decades before it actually
reaches and notch natural market share.
So it's really Internet
intergenerational game.
Then the other aspect is something about
efficiency.
A lot of policy is based on the
efficiency that we're going to improve.
Saudi has something built in around 15
percent of the next 25 years.
But efficiency doesn't come by itself,
it has his own dilemmas,
policy dilemmas,
because you know who's going to pay for
it.
Because if an end consumer not have the
expectation that end consumer price will
continuously rise,
why would you invest now upfront a lot
of money to invest in efficiency while
governments normally liked to say that
energy should be more affordable and
cheaper every day,
and here's kind of dichotomy to breach.
Another critical technology which we
have to really come to grips with.
Zoom is carbon capture and sequestration
CCS really to decarbonize the power
system.
I'm afraid if you want a lower carbon
system,
you can't do without a technological fix
called carbon capture and sequestration.